i got this your tweet
from david hookstead david
is uh let's see what he doesn't have
okay so you know him yeah he says beto
o'rourke says people who currently own
semi-automatic rifles should have them
confiscated 22 seconds let's let's let's
hear what mr o'rourke has to say i just
took the position that may not be
politically popular maybe two honest
that not only should no one be able to
purchase an ar-15 or an ak-47 because
they're designed to kill humans and that
high-impact high-velocity round will
just tear up everything inside you'll
bleed out before we can get you back to
life um but i don't think that the
people who have them right now in
civilian use should be able to keep them
i just took them now i wonder if there's
more to that but come on this is the guy
who said heck yeah we're taking your
ar-15
so now apparently he's coming back out
saying he's going to confiscate your
weapons yo they line they say no one's
talking about taking your guns and
they're like oh yeah we will
i wonder what their internal polling
shows
it shows that liberal so conservatives
are overwhelmingly pro-gun and democrats
are split so the overwhelming majority
of this country is like now we want to
keep our guns yeah then they come out
with these fake stats where they're like
most people support background checks
it's like okay yeah we have those
already so what do you mean by that and
they're like well when we ask people
they so so it's it's it's almost a
mountain bailey they'll say well no no
we mean uh um restricting private sales
requiring background checks there and
i'm like that's not what you asked
people in the poll
in the poll it said do you think there
should be background checks for gun
buyers and they say yes you didn't get
specific because at
almost every single point of sale
there's going to be a background check
then they say no no we mean shut up you
want a registry that's what they want
i i just think beto wants attention like
i yeah honestly like the the stunt that
he pulled at the press conference i'm
sure you guys covered that where he
walked up and talked and like it's just
a publicity stunt and i i don't like
stuff like that being made political
also just just for the sake of being
fair i also didn't like when governor
abbott used the shooter's name
immediately after it happened i didn't
like that either i thought we were all
on the same page like we're not going to
glorify these people i want to pull up
this tweet from jonathan height because
we're fans of his assessment but he he
has one of the worst tweets i've ever
seen he said the best thing i've ever
read about reducing gun violence is this
2017 essay by nick kristoff recently
updated if we take a public health
approach modeled after cars there is so
much we can do even in a divided country
wrong
and i'll tell you why
here's what he's proposing background
checks 22 of guns are obtained without
one and
you need a background check at any
federally licensed dealer there are some
private sales but whenever they're
talking about these these these tragic
events they were purchased legally
background checks didn't change it safe
storage trigger locks as well as guns
and ammunition stored separately
especially when children are in the
house well that's great someone kicks
your door in the middle of the night and
they're going to violate your wife and
you're like hold on i need to open the
safe with the bullets then open the safe
with the gun then load the met that then
load the the the rifle and then i can
save you honey and immunity for firearm
companies that's a subsidy to a
particular industry no it isn't it makes
no sense what are we going to do if if
someone manufactures glass bottles and
then someone uses that to crack someone
over the head you sue the bottle maker
it's like you're not supposed to commit
crimes protection orders
keep men who are subject to domestic
violence protection orders from having
guns we already do straw purchases we
are don't allow that ban bum stocks okay
that actually happened under trump but
that makes no sense because
full auto was never a big issue here ban
under 21s constitutional violation
ammunition checks experimentation with a
one-time background check for anybody
buying ammo we already have background
checks on people buying weapons what
would that accomplish research smart
guns researching means nothing doesn't
mean anything so this is you know for
for jonathan haight to say that this is
go you know even in a divided nation we
can do those things no you can't because
you have no idea what you're talking
about i'm not gonna even even pretend
that i know for the most part what i'm
talking about i'm not even an expert on
guns but i can look right away and be
like you have no idea what you're
talking about and that's the problem the
ignorant democrat voters are voting for
their feelings and they don't know
anything we demand background checks
okay you win
oh you guys all right i agree you win we
have background checks now next yeah
well you know these people committing
crimes are breaking every law in order
to do them do we need more laws yes
that will do it i think that'll fix it
there was a uh marco rubio got a bunch
of heat i think in like 2015 where he
marco rubio's claimed that no recent
mass shootings would have been prevented
by gun laws um and then glenn kessler of
the washington post the fact checker
over there uh not only didn't give it
any pinocchios he gave it the
rare gepetto like yeah no he's right
that all of the the mass shootings
wouldn't none of that unfortunately
would have been stopped uh
choose my words carefully here they
marco rubio said that
none of those shootings would have been
stopped by any sort of gun laws and
even
the washington post said yeah no he was
right about that and the problem is what
you were saying is that people are just
ignorant on the the issue yeah like my
biggest thing too is also just
asking questions about implementation oh
i just say what's an assault weapon oh i
say that too the first thing i think is
if you ask the average democrat voter
like what they believe in ar-15 is
they're going to tell you that the ar
stands for assault rifle and they're
going not going to be able to find them
to you that if they're going to think
that it's
i would guess like most of them think
that so uh shout out to our good friend
ethan klein he was talking on h3 and he
was mentioning something about people
going in front of uh abbott's house with
ar15s and he goes
i'm like is that what you think those
things do yeah you know they actually no
wonder you want to ban them well so
i am as someone who went to an art
school i am an expert on people who
don't know anything about guns
and so i remember
that's like embedding to research you
know like you're going it was like a
case study kind of thing yeah yeah i
went undercover thanks for doing that
for us you're welcome so i was having a
conversation with a friend
and she said to me that um
she was like well i don't think that we
should have like these semi-automatics
and i was like do you know what a
semi-automatic like it's semi-fully
you pull the trigger and it sprays the
bullets and i was like
no no no that's not what any of that
means and i tried to explain that that
was not the case uh and and their
response was to just insist that we
still didn't need to have them
i wish i had the clip but i remember
cool person in other ways by the way but
just was out to lunch on that one i
remember watching jesse smellette is
trending
probably because of that sorry i i
interrupted you he's got a new uh show
coming out on bet plus he's back at work
oh nice really yes are you serious yeah
he's he's directing and starring in a
show about um uh break dancing or
something like that something it's like
an lgbtq plus uh film that uh be plus is
making no he's trending because
everyone's saying amber hurt is just
just it's jesse's possible i love it
ah sorry what were you saying
oh no last week i was watching msnbc or
one of your big cable news networks
and they were talking about gun control
and like your point the both of the
anchors were like yeah we need gun
control have you ever shot a gun no i've
never shot a guy have you shot a gun no
no never i would never shoot a gun so we
have two people who have never shot a
gun talking about gun control clearly
not knowing anything about
the thing that they're trying to control
yeah they need to learn how to control
guns those two people remember
there you go remember that reporter who
got ptsd from firing yeah and then
people were replying with comments of
like them training their young daughters
to shoot it like yeah they're like this
is actually not that there's a video
going viral a little girl dual wielding
i don't know what she's got 1911's and
she's using two fingers to pull the
trigger and then they're like this is
child abuse look what they're doing to
that child and i'm like well the the
real problem is that they're having her
fire two handguns simultaneously which
is just terribly inaccurate there's no
reason to do that um
there's a meme i love and it said uh
actually maybe i can pull it up try and
find it i posted it on instagram it was
hilarious does jessie's millet actually
have a show i i can't tell that was that
i forget what the name of the
yeah we kind of mentioned in podluck
it's uh it's called mega country
about break dancing mega supporters that
would be that would be fantastic who
wander the streets of chicago at two in
the morning
i think here's here's the meme i got it
says children and firearm safety
children and guns are simply a bad idea
your average firearm is too unwieldy for
a typical child to operate in a safe and
effective manner that's right children
are much better suited to crew to crew
served weapons right the semi-stationary
characteristic of a mortar or heavy
machine gun relies less than the child's
physical strength and stamina and also
builds teamwork yeah and it shows a
little boy and little girl and shows
like a machine gun and a mortar and a
thumbs up
i actually had the thought after i don't
think i don't think that should be legal
after this texas meme or could they fly
drones from an ipad yeah they would be
better at that i was picturing like kids
third third graders getting gun safety
lessons in government school if it's
going to be in the united states
government schools that like if a
shooter comes in and kills the teacher
and there's 12 kids in the class ducking
for their desks and one of the kids sees
the the teacher's you know sidearm that
the teacher was killed before it could
use
the kid what do you just want him to
huddle there until he gets shot
no i want the kid to pick up the gun and
end the shooter like i don't care if
they're 9 or 15 or 21 if they can do it
do it well let's let's let's phrase this
in a legal manner
children should be capable of defending
their lives or the lives of others yes
just like anyone else yep i mean
when it comes to your life yes they
should
well they want more autonomy for kids
when it comes to
you know all the stuff that they
shouldn't have autonomy in but when it
comes to like actually teaching kids to
use guns like they used to in schools
like there are pictures from the six i
would say the 50s and 60s where
middle schoolers are learning to shoot
like they're learning marksmanship they
were competing with each other i think
that's such a great idea and i wish that
we hadn't gotten rid of that yeah uh
welding as well yeah idea carpentry
swords
sword fighting yeah we did that 101 with
professor pool yeah correct yes well no
james lindsay oh yeah yeah
i'm like way more you know he's like
trained with gian yeah i'm way more
bullish on gun rights for kids because
after this texas thing man the cops
stopped them from going in and stopping
it like you left these kids to their own
devices in a classroom as they were
getting mowed down i am not comfortable
with that yo something weird is going on
there because like the left is
entertaining conspiracy theories about
what happened yeah tell me well
the cops aren't cooperating anymore with
the investigation the police stopped the
intervention and so the left is like
what is going on well it serves their
narrative because they hate cops right
so when you have a story about the cops
barring parents from saving their kids
and not going in themselves they're like
hmm what's this all about
then you've got the uh one of the guys
involved one of the cops i guess got a
seat on the city council or something so
the left has been pushing these these
conspiracy theories well also i mean
what happened there is the perfect
example of what gun control does the
police stop law-abiding citizens from
protecting from protecting themselves
and people they care about while the
maniac who kills people still doesn't
gets away with it
and that is the function that those
police officers served in that instance
yeah
i'm like obviously it'd be ridiculous to
give a third grader the right to carry
open carry a handgun
in the presence of a supervised adult
that is licensed right maybe that you
could legalize their ability to handle
one for training purposes and then if it
hits the fan you know and it's wartime
in the classroom like it was in texas
last week
these these young soldiers can defend
themselves
young soldiers they have no other choice
at that point my god a girl smeared
blood on her face and laid down so that
she looked dead so that she didn't get
killed i would have rather that she dove
for a handgun and ended the guy
no one else is going to do it and i have
to say that i think the only way out of
this is to teach everyone responsibility
and i do mean everyone the only way to
stop active shooters like this is to
make them understand that if they walk
into a shop or store that they hope to
rob or a bank they will be met with
lethal force there is no other way out
i'm sorry to say it that is the way of
the world we've been very protected
we've lived in like this marshmallow
utopia for a really long time we have a
hard time seeing hard truths it is
interesting to see like my friends who
are all posting stuff about like uh acab
in like 2020 now saying well no you
don't need a gun
the cops are gonna show up and they're
gonna save you and then the cops in an
instance where the cops didn't show up
and save them it's like it's a horrible
example this is like the the like if
this if this was like a police if this
was a movie about the police this would
be like the opposite of a movie it's
like they're the actually the worst
people on earth you got to speak their
language here's what i say to them do
you think that police are racist
well of course yes they say okay do you
think that white supremacists will give
up their guns if the guns are made
illegal no of course they won't okay do
you think racist cops will enforce the
law against white supremacists who
refuse to give their guns and they say
yeah of course they won't do you think
that police will use the justification
of gun checks to uh raid and violate the
the fourth amendment rights of black
people well yeah so you're saying you
want to pass a law that you think they
won't that racists won't enforce against
other racists but will be weaponized
against black and brown people yeah
sounds good
i mean that's that's the entirety of
their narrative cops are racist cops
don't cops protect other racists cops
arbitrarily enforce against black people
so they want laws and i said you know
what's going to happen i was like so
what a racist cop can go to any black
person's home and just say gun check
because you passed the red flag laws we
but i don't have any guns well we got a
red we gotta search their house too bad
i'm like is that what you're advocating
for i mean all gun control is racist
well left-wing positions don't involve
that much for thought here's what's
required you say i have good intentions
pass my law okay well what is your law
going to result in i have good
intentions
okay what what is the law going to do
how do you enforce it all of the
concerns you mentioned are those but i
want good thing
and then and then i have questions about
good thing sheamus you want bad thing
yeah i don't want you want bad thing you
ask questions
that is literally the entire strategy
why do you want that thing yeah tim pool
is on the cover of the newspaper the
next day man want bad thing
it's totally insane and
basically the whole idea is let's look
at uh policy based on the intentions and
not the results or the incentives that
said policy creates culturally can can
this be a multi-faceted approach like i
i'm all you know all with you on the gun
side too but npr
two three years ago did a mass shootings
can be contagious research shows which
is
extremely difficult the way the media
covers it too like can we all get on the
same page of how we're covering this
sort of stuff like you have to talk
about
there there are people in media who want
to shock to make money
so they're not going to tell you the
truth
they're then going to accuse us of
trying to shock to make money but the
fact that they will show the face and
the name of these murderers when what
they want is attention right and they'll
see here's his manifesto read it
everything that he wanted here you go
well worse still is what happens is when
the manifesto comes out and clearly the
person's insane the media will latch
onto anything that smears the right yeah
so like here's a guy in uh was it
buffalo i think yeah who said he was he
was a communist
he outright said he's like i'm
authoritarian left and they're like he's
right-wing
like well he was racist interesting but
you know he was crazy the adl says
racism is right-wing
i'm not even kidding if a racist attacks
someone it's listed as a right wing
attack
so it's funny like the adl says right
wing is anti-government right-wing is
like uh bad they want bad thing right
it's like racism bad therefore racism
right but here's if a black nationalist
who commits a racist murder is left-wing
and the left was like what
what like how is that left-wing
they asked the adl it's like black and
white are left and right i guess that's
that's that's how they think
if an asian commits a hate crime against
the hispanic is that right when you're
left-wing that would probably normally
not be listed on the adl's website yeah
yeah no i don't know north yeah
they just put a question mark on the map
yeah they're like we don't know what
that means and we're not going to engage
with it
but we had we had we've had black
nationalist killings we have one in
brooklyn and they say it's left-wing
it's like but those guys have the same
ideology as hitler
well you know he was black though it's
like okay
but the white dude who who hates the
government like leftists take the
anti-far anarchists no i i shouldn't say
that many left-wing anarchists hate the
government and they're left like they're
you know anarcho-communists or whatever
but if the person doesn't explicitly
explain that they're socialist it's
right-wing yep okay dude i feel like a
hurric as a tornado of identity politics
ripped my brain out of my body in the
last like 37 minutes did you guys feel
like that that was a great phrase it's
it's just the the identity politics are
thick in this one yeah i don't know how
to respond to it because i can't i feel
like no no it's one of those things
where like acknowledging it causes it i
don't think that's it i think we do have
to acknowledge the division
but
i don't know it's i don't know is it
well is it identity politics to
acknowledge that specific political
groups are trying to do things that
they've outwardly stated they're trying
to do
if you just assume everyone in the group
is like adheres to the group authority
it is so if 10 people walk into a bank
and they're all wearing the same outfits
and they all came in the same truck and
then nine of them commit a bank robby
bank robbery and the last guy's like you
go get him guys and then you're like
you're all bank robbers he goes i didn't
do anything or would they get arrested
as charges accomplished he was the yeah
if he was the driver no no just someone
who is hanging out how about you just
standing there outside a group of ten
people walking into a bank all wearing
the same clothes nine of them commit the
robbery and the tenth one just stands
there watching and cheers them on you
thought it was a flash mob yeah how bad
would your luck be if you just happen to
be wearing the same clothing as bank
robbers that day and you walk in and
they start robbing like wait a minute
you ever see the thomas crown affair no
when like the guy steals the painting
and everyone's dressed in the same
clothes and so they're all moving around
like everyone's like where'd he go it's
him no he's there he's there like
there's just like some random guys
wearing the same clothes and he's like
oh crap
it's tough
when i get it's tough when we talk about
the democrats or like the left because i
know there's people that are
democrat that aren't crazy and then same
with the right right but that's why we
say they're they're npcs
because if at this point you're like
yeah jimmy dore had a segment the young
turks was ragging on him because he was
like if you're anti-war you vote for
trump and i'm like that is objectively
true correct trump didn't start any new
wars and he was pulling our trips out of
the middle east joe biden started a new
war oh well i should i shouldn't blame
him for something you know i say he he
put his he put our troops back into
these existing wars like syria and now
we have ukraine and they're sending
money and funds so it's like oh more new
war is happening i can't blame him
that's that's on russia but if you voted
for trump you have abraham accords what
is it uh was it israel in the uae with a
piece with a free trade agreement i
think yeah that's correct
that was uh almost none of my friends
had heard anything about that when we
talked about that when we talked about
this and they're like why would you
first of all i didn't tell them who i
voted for they just kind of assumed
whoever i might have voted for because i
i didn't uh post biden memes and talk
about that stuff and i just asked myself
do you have any idea about either the
abraham accords or the the pros the
progress we've made in the middle east
or north korea and they're just like
he's racist and i'm like uh
i can't oh wow he is what did he say
i tried to explain it in the examples
like the thing like you mentioned with
brandon strzok about uh with uh what was
that with the
insulting the yeah for me it was the
ms-13 gang members and how they framed
how he said it as all
uh members you know all people from
mexico and it was like when i saw the
clip it was so egregious i'm like
you have to be at least somewhat aware
but most people aren't going to take the
time to actually look into it so i just
you know i always i always just you know
socratic method or people say like yeah
well trump's a racist they'll go oh
really oh yeah what did he do
and then they're just like i don't know
that's crazy
yeah so you don't know that he did
anything racist here's another good art
school story i was having a conversation
with somebody and they mentioned that
they thought trump was racist against
immigrants and i pointed out that
immigrant was not a race and
they said that we should stop talking
politics
what usually happens is um i'll say like
what what do you mean
they'll if they'll say something like
trump is is racist against you know
muslims yeah they'll mention the muslim
ban i'll be like muslims not a race like
do you mean religious oh yeah he's like
bigoted against religions and i'm like
oh like you like but the countries that
he banned is like venezuela is included
on that list and they'll be like well
that was a red herring i'll be like oh
you think that he was just like it was a
conspiracy
like he was pretending to ban venezuela
so that he could secretly ban muslims
and that was like a plot
and they'll be like well i'll be like i
don't know is that what you think like
the government was secretly plotting to
ban muslims so they pretended to ban
people from venezuela is that what
happened
i just don't i think i think it's just a
simple answer it's like trump banned a
bunch of countries because the obama
administration's doj or our state
department said there was risks there
but you know whatever man thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you